hello everyone a lot of interesting
things have happened since I've been in
Germany the first five rounds of the
Tata Steel chess tournament Magnus
Carlsen won the second title event at
leat chess under a different name not to
Danny - donkey anymore I've heard he
cover Nakamura played a match against a
hustler from South Africa so a lot of
things to cover but this here game which
one at an island versus Fabiano Caruana
this is round three of the Tata Steel
chess tournament was the most requested
game in the comment so I haven't seen
the game until yesterday but I've seen
the diagram from the winning move by
Anand and it's it's quite amazing the
the title of the video might seem a bit
harsh you know being his worst nightmare
from India but when I saw the diagram it
immediately reminded me of Anand the win
against Caruana from the Sinquefield Cup
last year so let's see this game and so
far I think Anand is has four points and
he's tied in second place with onigiri
and I think I think there are three
people in second place in first place
still shocked their mama dro with four
and a half points and an interesting
game today might be Carlsen versus holy
fun who if and didn't really have a
great tournament so far only two draws
against kurakin and Vladimir Kramnik so
I guess she knows her way around
Russians so she might surprise today
against Magnus Carlsen but let's get
back to this game so Alan has the white
pieces and he opens the game with E 4
and this seems to be a fashion I like 1
year and everyone plays d4 Knight f3 and
then the other year everyone
then again plays efore and Caruana seems
prepared for this he goes e5 we have 9
f3 and Knight to f6 the Petrov defense
something he also used against Magnus
Carlsen in in round 1 so Knight captures
on e5 d 6 clicking tonight back Knight
f3 and the Knight captures on e4 and the
d4 by Anand instead of D for Carlsen
played the Queen to e2 in his game in
the first round so d4 by Islander this
is the classical line d5 Bishop to d3
Bishop to d6 both players Castle we have
c4
and c6 there are some other options
available here
like maybe Knight to f6 defending the d5
pawn that way but that that does seem
like a loss of a tempo but it's also a
variation you could maybe defend it with
Bishop to e6 Khurana goes for c6 so we
have Queen to c2 adding more pressure to
thee for night and now Knight to a6 it
does seem like an awkward place for the
night but the night can't come to a 6
would would a threat of night to before
attacking the Queen and the bishop so
white also has to waste a move a3 we had
Bishop to g4 now threatening to capture
an f3 and mess up White's pawn structure
and we have Knight to e5 now placing the
Nisan and denied on a nice central
square also harassing the bishop on g4
so Bishop to a5 and b4 now we have nice
to see 7 and here we have this very nice
move by Anand f3 and it seems like his
winning at least a piece you know if you
move the knight obviously you lose the
bishop on f5 but as Caruana already
played the petal defense twice in this
in this tournament and in round one
against Carson it here against Anand
he's obviously very prepared for this so
Bishop to g6 and here we have c5
attacking the bishop on d6 but of course
the main question is why not capture the
knight on e4 well if F captures knight
on e4 then you get Bishop captures on e5
d captures on e5 d captures now on e4
attacking the bishop on d3 and it really
doesn't matter what you do black is
getting much more out of this position
for example if you capture the next
Queen to d4 check picks up the rook
maybe okay you can't afford to capture
the bishop first and then look after the
King moves but you know you win the
exchange at least and if you don't
capture your only other option is to
move the bishop the only available
square z2 after Bishop to e2 again Queen
to d4 check and you lose the whole
rook here so after Bishop to g6 c5 first
either forcing the bishop back or
forcing him to capture Fabiano captures
Bishop cap
sunny 5d captures an ephah and now
Knight to g5 and Fabiana spent a lot of
time on this Knight g5 move he spent I
think around 25 minutes we have Bishop
to b2 b4 + f4 now and this was probably
what Fabiana was calculating the one he
played Knight to g5 this f4 move and
here he played Knight to d5 he offers
his knight and g5 but in exchange he
will grab the rook on f1 so F captors
and g5 aren't accepted the challenge we
have Knights - III attacking the Queen
and the rook Queen moves and now first
Bishop captures the three Queen captures
tenth knight Knight captures an f1 King
captures an f1 and Queen to g5 capturing
the pawn so if you look at this position
and has now two pieces for the rook and
of course it's a better position for
white but you know you have to play it
Knight to e2 you have to develop those
pieces Queen captures on e5 and Knight
to f3 now first improving the position
of the night keeping the Queen from the
central square and only then will I
don't recapture the pawn on b4 Queen to
h5 and now Queen captures and b4 with
with a with a nice tempo and a very nice
threat of Queen captures and g7
checkmate
so Fabiano defends this f6 we have Queen
Queen to c4 check King h8 and now Bishop
to c1 rook F to e8 Bishop to f4 a5 and
Bishop to d6 so a nice maneuver by Anand
Bishop from v2 to c1 to f4 to d6 and now
this Bishop will be a very powerful
piece here also you know useful in
protection of the king side now this
knight on f3 can move also protecting
the rook from AAA to be developed by
rook a to D 8 D file is now closed for
the rook so very nice very nice choice
for almond we had a capture some before
and now Queen capture some before and
Queen to d5 it seems that
Anand is ready to capture the pawn on b7
and why would you allow this of course
Fabiano could have played going to f7
but now okay he does defend upon and b7
but it's a very passive position for
black instead he decided after the
screen to before to play queen d5 to
gain a more act more gain more activity
for the Queen there will be now Queen to
d3 check ID checks ideas the Rope will
also be able to come into the game so I
don't again accept the challenge Queen
captures on b7 we have h6 making some
breathing room for the King so you can
activate those rooks King to g1 not
allowing Queen d3 with tempo so rock to
a for now karana finally activates the
rook we have h3 also not making pone
opponent h2 a weakness and also giving
the King some more breathing space rook
the c4 and we have Queen to be 2 now
Queen to d3 rook to a 2 under doesn't
allow karana to play rook to c2 and we
have Queen to d1 now with check King to
h2 and rook to c1 so it does seem like
it could get unpleasant for the White
King there's always this Queen to h1
check that you have to take into
consideration but even after Queen to h1
after King to g3 there's really not a
good follow up so you have to improve on
this
I don't start supposed to be pushing his
past bone we have a 4 f5 we have Queen
to b7 and now F for the thread is of
course if if Anand for some reason
captures the c6 spawned and Queen to h1
is checkmate so you have to prevent this
you have to capture the f4 pawn Bishop
captures on f4 and now Rock after some
c5 now Caruana grabs the c5 pawn and
creates a passed pawn of his own the C
pawn rook to d2 we're attacking the
Queen and Queen captures on a4 and now
Queen to f7
rook the g8 and here we have Bishop to
e5 and now you have you have all sorts
of threats here it's a very unpleasant
position for example if you play
something like let's say Queen to b4
trying to defend or something then this
Bishop captures on g7 check that's
that's a pretty big threat
a rogue character so now Queen to f8
check will pick up the rope
on c5 so not a lot of moves here for
Caruana after this Bishop to e5 move he
played Queen to c4 here he offers an
exchange of Queens and it's there's
really no move here for Caruana after
Allen place his next move and I know
this game was played a couple of days
ago you've probably already seen the
move but in case some of you haven't
feel free to pause the video here find
it the move on and played it's a
crushing move quite a no it's a
brilliancy so don't feel free to pause
it and find it for yourselves so I will
as usual give it a couple of seconds
okay
that for those of you who found it
congratulations it's a brilliant move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy a show the move and played was
rook to d6 and this is a beautiful move
there are there are so many options for
black here but none of them actually
work the most blunt one actually Queen
captures an f7 why not capture the Queen
rook captures on h6 and this is
checkmate the pawn on g7 is obviously
pinned instead maybe maybe you try
something else maybe try to capture the
bishop rook captures but then the rook
is no longer defending the Queen and c4
Queen captures on c4 you lose the Queen
and the game are there any other options
here well you could try maybe King to h7
so the King would now be protecting the
exponent but now simply Queen to hd6
check King has to go back and now Queen
captures on h6 is checkmate and aside
from these three variations we also have
the option of maybe going Queen to c1 so
the Queen from C one would be defending
the pawn on h6 but this falls to a very
nice rook to d8 and black is again
without a move
the threat is of course Queen captures
on g8 this will be checkmate if you
capture then Queen captures on g7 will
be checkmate whatever black plays there
is always a nice checkmate lurking by so
yeah after this rook to d6 move Caruana
resigned the game and this brilliancy
was composed by former world champion
Vishwanath on
and I don't know so far any tournament
uh none plays any game on places is
actually brilliant I mean it doesn't
seem like he has bad games for quite a
while now and if anything he definitely
shows that he he he should I mean they
should have allowed him somehow to play
in the candidates either invite more
player to the candidates or I don't know
it is just doesn't seem fair that a
player of this caliber will not be
playing in in the next series and of the
candidates but yeah that's the game
regardless of that and still manages to
dazzle us which has brilliancy and I do
hope you enjoyed this game as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon and just uh something that
is unrelated to chess if any of you have
seen the movie man from Earth there is
no a sequel man from Earth wholesome
I've seen it and the movie is free to
watch you can download it for free you
can stream it for free there are no you
know legal obligations for you so if you
enjoy the first part you know you can
watch the second part I enjoyed it I
likes you know a fiction story like that
so yeah once again I do hope you enjoyed
it then go for watching and I will see
you soon